the number one thing i know that will
work for this audience
is having a foundation of two core
things always following the underpriced
attention not the mature attention i
tell you everybody focuses on the mature
attention because it's easy it's what
you're stuck in that along with what are
we going to do about a sustained content
model what we need to talk about is
underpriced attention why was i doing
email in 1997 for my dad's wine shop
because i had 93 open rates that's a
long time ago that newsletter now gets
18 open rates why was i doing facebook
fan pages like ham in 2012 and 13 for
the people that were doing it here you
know why and then instagram and then
this so it's always moving if you don't
find something that works for you
forever you won't do it so like if
you're a real business person like i am
spending three hours a day to make
videos is not going to work for you you
got family and you got a business to run
but can you do a podcast once a week
strictly for the 13 pieces of content it
produces for you because you film it and
post produce it
all of you can because i'm busy as [ __ ]
and i do it 10 12 pieces of content a
day is the only answer to the thing
you're thinking about
so it's where we're at let's get right
into it because i have 20 here and then
we're gonna do q a
um
that really
excited me that video for a lot of
reasons most of all because it ties in
so nicely to what i would like to
accomplish here while we're all together
i do not believe even though it's been
the majority
of what i've been talking about and
producing content around that i've
pushed hard enough
for this room to understand that
literally the variable
of success in the business that you're
running
is
content creation that makes sense
of the moment
even though this has been at nausea
what i've been talking about for a
decade the stakes are so uncomfortably
high
for the people in this room because of
two things one the platforms that have
the attention are changing right now and
every time they change crazy [ __ ]
happens leaders lose market share
and hungry emergers take market share
which is fun because there's people
winning here and there's people that are
trying to get more so it touches
everyone in here and i'll go into why
two days ago in a breakfast meeting with
four key members of my content team we
took instagram from the number one
priority spot to the number five
priority spot like to give you context
of how serious like the timing of this
talk is awesome so
yay
so i want to talk a lot about that but i
also want to talk about
why
whether it's literally i think this is
now obvious running for office
in any politics around the world whether
it's selling sneakers whether it's
becoming famous like everything
is about supply and demand
demand
is something one has to create
that has been done a million different
ways through the test of time as a real
estate agent in the 80s it was
really being the queen or king of your
local area whether it was bench ads or
direct mail or being ridiculously
involved in the local sports or the pta
like you just physically networked in
2023 it is virtually networking
right
it starts with content and then it comes
down to like how much in the grind are
you when you saw that if i know people
were getting settled but if you saw that
video that little reply email like i'm
in for 15 at like one in the morning i
wrote that
every dm or reply that anybody has ever
gotten here from my account is me
there's no some weird [ __ ] intern in
japan doing that [ __ ] for me
that's why we have a team gary account
team gary may reply because just of
scale but
most people
get fancy
before they've earned it there's a lot
of people at this conference in this
room right now talking big game
but aren't actually willing to put in
the dirt work in the trenches to get
what their mouth is saying
and the reason i'm double motivated is
not only is the content
framework changing in front of our eyes
and i've always over the last decade
have won in those shifts
and that's why we're going to win again
and that's why i'm desperate for the 13
people that really listen to me today
and do something about it they're going
to win
but it's also happening when this
industry is about to have a macro issue
which means
it's supply and demand not only is it
important to win when there's an
attention shift there's
even double importance when your macro
industry is going to get squeezed and
there is no confusion to anybody in this
room that the macro industry is going to
get squeezed because the math is clear
as day you could be optimistic as [ __ ]
and delusional and put your head in the
sand you're more than welcome but the
reality is shit's about to hit the fan
in some shape or form nobody knows if
it's this that i don't know if it's o8 i
don't know if it's a one i don't know if
it's 87 but the math is clear
and so i don't know you're more than
welcome to have a strategy that looks
like this i hope [ __ ] stays good
or you can look at what has already
happened and depending on where you are
in the country some of you have already
felt it
and then the people that haven't felt it
are making up dumb things like well
they're feeling it but we're not going
to feel it our market's different the
macro market is going to be affected
so what gets super fun about that is all
these [ __ ] talks of the last decade
of my life have been all about timing
this is all timing and so i come to you
this morning in what i believe is
perfect timing like literally perfect
timing and i hope this framework of like
what i just said really gets some
people's attention to double down on
whatever they're feeling whether that's
fear or ambition i hope you [ __ ]
double down and what i want you to
double down on is content
it's as simple as that let there be no
confusion i don't care how great your
reputation is i don't care how many
contacts you have in your cell phone
what you're doing by not going all at
all in on content is leaving opportunity
on the table it's not that you're going
to go out of business it's that somebody
sitting next to you's cousin that's in
the same market as you is going to pick
up market share against you if they go
into content when they're not as good as
you
or if you're really good you're just
leaving being double the size of your
business now this is real talk now back
to mentality a lot of people here might
not want it me and i mean that like to
me this is about do you want to grow the
business i don't think everyone should
grow a business you might be in a life
cycle where you want to spend more time
with your family you want to chill out
maybe you're selling that's all good
everything that i'm talking about is
strictly do you want it to grow and
sometimes grow is important because if
we are right body energy wise that the
macro market gets squeezing one of the
reasons you need it to grow
is so it stays at the same level that
you're at right now
you're fighting for opportunity
you all know this how many people have
been in this game for over 15 years
raise your hand
raise them higher just so i get a sense
this is awesome so you 15-year plus ogs
know exactly what i'm about to say
which is
when the market is awesome
even f players make money
and they think they're a players but
they're not because the market right
you've been you've seen it that's what's
about to happen right now
and it's a tricky one right because for
some of the 15 plus ogs in this room
you just might not have as much energy
as you did 20 years ago when you crushed
during a down market you might have got
a little soft
you like fishing on the weekend
right you like instead of grinding email
you like like and so like this is just
real where am i at as a human being
not everybody should triple down and
bleed for it this period because maybe
you're not in that place maybe you've
been saving your money and you just
don't want to and that's awesome but for
anybody who does
or for anybody who needs to because
you've been living a bigger lifestyle
then you can actually afford and you
don't have savings and the market really
needs to be where it's at you need to
get very serious with me in this session
about the following if you are not
producing 10 15 20 pieces of internet
content for facebook youtube instagram
snapchat all these platforms a day
you are vulnerable
and it's a big ass number for the people
in here that are making two a week
when i'm out here like i want you to put
out 15 pieces of content a day and it
doesn't mean
15 original pieces of content that you
make it means do you do a podcast i mean
look at my content how many people here
follow me give me a sense
thank you so for the people that raised
their hand
you see it
i'm not out here i'm not [ __ ] dancing
on tick tock
i'm not [ __ ] spending time to make
content i'm living my life created a
framework that allows me to produce
post-production
as much as i love the origin story of
how i got to this stage with that video
because i love his hustle and i love
everything about what i just saw
the single reason i'm here and my
speaking fee is not low
but the single reason i am on stage
right now is for the content
the single reason i am on stage right
this second
the only reason i do podcasts
with other people which is why often you
see me put people on and do their first
podcast is because i'm not doing it
because i'm trying to get audience from
their podcast i don't need rogan i want
to put some kid on that's on the way
because the real reason i'm doing it is
one to do karma and put the next
generation on and two i just need the
content for me
it doesn't matter who's asking me the
question i need my answer and i need to
chop it the [ __ ] up and i need to pound
it down your [ __ ] throats on every
platform in the world
got it
so like a lot of people in all these
business circles and you probably census
so many people come up to me every day
dm real life it happened already twice
here so many people sense that i'm
slightly different
and it's because i am
and what i'm just trying to do is get
all of you to be different with me
because it works
and it's good
but what it requires is a lot of
self-awareness
the biggest reason people don't win and
have stopped the people in here who have
stopped doing a lot of content because
they don't see the roi
is only because they didn't put
themselves in a position to succeed it's
like it's like getting into better shape
right like cool you can starve yourself
for two weeks that's not sustainable
like cool you could like like if you
don't find something that works for you
forever you won't do it
so like if you're a real business person
like i am spending three hours a day to
make videos is not gonna work for you
you got family and you got a business to
run
but can you do a podcast once a week
strictly for the 13 pieces of content it
produces for you because you film it and
post produce it
all of you can because i'm busy as [ __ ]
and i do it
so what we need to figure out today is a
couple things by the way not everybody
here should be on video
because you're not good at it
or because you can get better at it
maybe just really don't like it comma
you're an unbelievable writer
and that writing can be absolutely
transcribed into post-production videos
like maybe you just maybe you're more
comfortable audi you love talking but
something happens when the camera goes
on you and you know and i'm empathetic i
get all the dms i read them people don't
like the way they look their weight
women's you know like oh
all the lady entrepreneurs like easy for
you gary i gotta do makeup and [ __ ]
hair and i'm like i get it
i'm like or you don't give a [ __ ] what
people think of your looks
right like seriously and by the way
that's not a that's like a we need
self-esteem of who we are as human
beings not how much money we make or
what we look like
that's how you can get to making video
fast
and by the way all those people that
[ __ ] on you and say you [ __ ] look
terrible like feel bad for them don't
feel bad for you
imagine living a life where you go
around social media and try to make
people feel sad do you know how [ __ ]
up sad your life is
don't feel bad for you feel bad for them
you need to figure out a sustainable
model to produce content let me talk to
you about something i call underpriced
attention for the last 15 years i've
built my entire career on underpriced
attention
whatever the attention of the world was
on that most people didn't understand
that the world was on it yet is where i
produced the most content and went the
hardest
i know a lot of you had all sorts of
feelings when i was pushing musically
and tick tock six years ago
that was going to be the one that i was
going to be wrong about
what you have to pay attention to is
where are people actually consuming
and don't make up excuses like well gary
my customers aren't on tick tock
because that's what you all did 24
months ago and now all your customers
are on tick tock
right
so
what we need to talk about is
underpriced attention why was i doing
email in 1997 for my dad's wine shop
because i had 93 open rates
that's a long time ago that newsletter
now gets 18 open rates
why was i doing facebook fan pages like
ham in 2012 and 13 for the people that
were doing it here you know why and then
instagram and then this so it's always
moving let me give you straight from the
horse's mouth where the underpriced
attention sits right now number one this
is wild
facebook fan pages
let me throw a bomb at you for three
years i didn't even think about facebook
between big corporations that
vaynermedia works with canceling
facebook because of the politics and the
trump stuff and the democrat stuff and
all the politics you have big companies
like i don't know if this is exactly
true but companies like bmw and
coca-cola and all these that used to
pour 50 million in have gone to zero
then for some of you that definitely are
in the trenches with dtc and retargeting
ios 14 5 [ __ ] up people that really
know how to do math right
so that took away another goodrillion
dollars of dtc brands that you would go
to their website you wouldn't fill out
the shopping cart you know this you saw
it they followed you everywhere you
didn't buy the sneakers you saw the
sneaker ad 800 times until you just
[ __ ] gave up and bought the sneakers
because you didn't want to see the
[ __ ] ad anymore
so that money's gone
all of this i love when everyone's like
gary the algorithm [ __ ] me the
algorithm
did not [ __ ] you sarah
you're just not interesting as you were
six months ago or aren't changing or
your audience is changing or somebody
else took the algorithm is unemotional
and just wants money
and just wants attention
nobody's shadow banned here you just
suck now
so
what happens is it's all supply and
demand how many people post organically
how many people run ads how many people
are on the other side consuming
facebook as i'm sure we all know is not
in the consuming place it was in 2015
because instagram and tick tock and
other things have taken away
what just happened though is the
stuff that's coming in on the supply has
gone down so much on the ad side that
the organic facebook fan page content is
exploding
i couldn't give a bigger piece of advice
than telling all of you especially some
of the young dogs in here who never even
did facebook they started with instagram
to get very serious about facebook fan
pages and for this industry the age demo
that's on there
it's really important i would get your
facebook fan page game up number one
number two
youtube shorts
i don't know if this has hit your radar
yet how many people here and don't lie
because i'll look it up and then call
you out and destroy your brand
raise your hand if you're actively
making content for youtube shorts raise
your hand
very solid
but this is great look what just
happened hey that's solid great stuff
like this is fairly early last six
months nine months
but look this is a pretty legit crowd we
got some hands up but 95 98 did not huge
opportunity youtube shorts is tick tock
except it's youtube which means it's
searchable
youtube if you don't know is the second
biggest search engine in the world
google is number one youtube is number
two for some of you that have dyslexic
tendencies like i do you know why
because we don't read well and so we
need to listen or watch to learn
so if you make youtube shorts that are
titled very smartly
that are localized to your business or
you could do some real damage because
unlike a youtube video that if everybody
here posted for the first time would get
seven views
like tick tock your first youtube short
might get a hundred thousand views
it is pure virality it's huge it's
double huge like as much as the next
thing that's going to come out of my
mouth is tick tock and i want you to do
it i know for a lot of you youtube is
going to work even better because of the
search component that is not the same
dynamic that happens in tick tock so the
fact that for me if i have your job
and i know the mortgage real estate i
know what i know the room the fact that
i would spend my time on facebook fan
page first
youtube short second
tick tock third
is a profound shift
in a room full of people that have
instagram first
and i know
that
people are feeling their instagram
numbers stalling
and declining
because it's macro
it's declining because the supply and
demand curve is off
the supply's high
the demand everybody under 30 went to
tick
tock that's the game forever
so in very simplest terms
the number one thing i know that will
work for this audience
is having a foundation of two core
things always following the underpriced
attention not the mature attention and
oh
when i tell you everybody focuses on the
mature attention because it's easy it's
what you're stuck in instagram
that
along with what are we gonna do about
a sustained content model
i think it's an interview show i will
always say this to this industry in an
industry that does their business
locally
standing up an interview show that
interviews people locally
and then chopping that up will work if
you interview the principal of the high
school
and do the right titling on a youtube
short
do you know how many people decide where
they want to buy a home based on the
education framework enough a lot enough
that if they watch the interview of the
principal that they're trying to decide
if they're going to go into this town is
being interviewed by you and you happen
to be selling homes that's called
business
interview shows are easy
because you just have to do a little
prep and if you're like me you do no
prep and you just ask generic questions
and you roll with it
hey principal how's it going
i really need to figure out some
sentence in this room that unlocks you
to realize 10 12 pieces of content a day
is the only answer to the thing you're
thinking about
since we're at attention
and content and information is the only
game and other things have gotten mature
when i was doing seo and sem in 1999
that was underpriced attention
how many people here have been doing scm
for their business for over 15 years
raise your hand anybody
right just a couple some of you remember
like remember how good of a deal that
was
the stuff that you used to pay 48 cents
for is now 73
supply and demand
i need you to understand supply and
demand of attention and i need you to
understand that it's going to be content
for a long time we are within the half
decade of people watching tick tock on
television 24 hours a day
social
networks
have won the next decade brand and
business is built in social
you can do other things you've got
tactics that work i'm sure
direct mail outdoor
networking you know what to do it's
tried and true
to get value out of me being here today
i need this to be the moment you finally
said [ __ ] it i'm gonna go try it again
or [ __ ] it i'm gonna try for the first
time or [ __ ] it i'm gonna go 4x harder
because
it's really this wild moment
in time where all the attention's
reshifting
and the macro industry is going to
decrease which means
the winners in this space are going to
win and the winners in my opinion are
going to be the content producers
and you've got to find your way and it's
tough because the platforms i'm telling
you are video based
you know everybody loved instagram
because it was easy
i'm gonna take a photo
and it's gonna look real good after i
filter the [ __ ] out of myself
and then i'm gonna write a couple
sentences and it's gonna be super cool
that is not the current marketplace i
know you want it to be because that's a
[ __ ] load easier than what you need to
do now but whether it's a podcast a
local show
one offs
going to need to figure out what your
pillar content is
so that you then can cut up and produce
you're also more than welcome if you
love the game and you've got the time to
produce for it
but i know it's not going to be
sustainable for most of you which is why
i'm pushing this pillar and and i put i
put this out a long time ago and a lot
of people built businesses and many
different industries off of it but i
think if you google and maybe somebody
here can confirm it right now but if you
put you know um
gary vaynerchuk content model 84 pieces
i put that a long time ago it's
obviously the macros right some of the
you know details obviously change but
it'll give you a sense of what i'm
talking about of like you know make a
macro thing post produce again so many
people here raise their hand following
me it's all i do it's very obvious to
you you see what i do i re i bring up
stuff from nine years ago and then clip
me talking about something about night
like you just have to put yourself in a
position to actually do it but i'm
telling you and i'll leave with this and
we'll go into the chat
it's the answer to the quiz
you cannot leave las vegas
and not produce a lot of content if you
want to grow or sustain you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want
you're not my children i actually give
no [ __ ]
i would just prefer you win because it's
nice and i like getting the emails four
years later three years ago later like
it's nice i'd like you to win
this is the one thing you can control
the most
i know it's around self-esteem and
self-awareness of how to produce the
macro thing written word audio video
figure it out but figure it out
thank you
[Music]
you